so we're off to go for a little hike
it's cold I'm not used to this my blood
is my blip I'm cold is my blood thin ask
the pharmacist like what is this
he's a Squatch watch hat don't use this
to promote this Oh Bree Bree said the
hats ugly wait I wanted her yerba that's
a coffee oh I'll be a second I'm coming
after you looks so cute over there just
all bundled up I'm shopping what are you
shopping for it needs a sweater it's
cold out where here it wait wait where
are we whoa oh that's where we are and
here we go we're geared up Jenna where's
your gear me so mean what are
responsible for having the necessary
skills knowledge and equipment for a
safe and environmentally sensitive and
physical nature nature it's a little
warmer than Iceland Iceland was freezing
but I had so much fun eh
now time for lunch hope you guys enjoy
my really great hyper lapses gentle shot
her first one I was so rushed it was
like let's go let's go my braids are
just like sticking out of my head we've
had a slight detour in the middle of
nowhere there's a Walmart i pre-ordered
my smash brothers from yesterday here
but then I ended up buying you the
targets and I have to go in and get the
game and return it we're also gonna get
a color for bow because this current
color is too big for him he needs extra
small he need a cat collar we're here at
Walmart I finally returned my game I'm
blogging on the tiniest camera known to
human man it's not true
but I need to get some other little
things I've got some cold weather gear
because honestly it's a lot colder here
than I thought it was gonna be should
have packed like we were going to
Iceland get it okay I have to get the
I've got to get the tombola big pizza I
care about it it's my facebook
embarrassing it's cheese cheese cheese
oh no little bit apart
oh no it's pretty sturdy yep still still
filming you coulda knocked my help
alright guys I hope you enjoyed today's
fun vlog there'll be more fun tomorrow I
don't know what we're gonna do though
we'll be here tomorrow the puppy will be
back anyway I'm gonna go I have to ice
my leg because we uh we went hiking
today and guess what I have an injury my
sustainment walking I know honestly I
took the ice in it I hit myself in the
foot with it like right in my Inc